this story begins in California to be
more specific here in an unspecified
studio lot this is the story of a TV
producer a physicist and the man who
brought them both together that's Wendy
I one of the co producers of Marvel's
agent Carter in 2015
ABC released the show agent Carter about
a secret agent working in the late 1940s
in season two they debuted a character
named Jason Wilkes Jason is a scientist
who works at isodyne energy and a
science character needs to sound like a
real scientist kind of like this Peggy
enters to find Howard at the chalkboard
with books lambda is animated things
constant divided by MC except we can't
calculate them without an accurate
reading of your mass no mass no
wavelength so you need to write science
e dialogue right sciency stuff on the
chalkboard and have a science e looking
lab but you don't have any science
writers on staff no unfortunately we do
not so what did you do
we called our friends up at the National
Academy of Sciences IB change it's Rick
this is Rick hey I'm Rick I work at the
National Academy of Sciences we connect
scientists and engineers with people in
Hollywood people like Wendy yeah we
connected her with Clifford hi my name
is Clifford Johnson I am a professor in
the physics and astronomy department at
USC so it goes like this
Rick pears Clifford with Wendy and they
work together to bring real science into
TV shows yeah yeah yeah for example I
got an email one time saying so how do
you build an atomic bomb and I had to
sort of help them with that it was a lot
of fun Rick's team has a database with a
lot of scientists in it over 2000 and
they've worked on some major blockbuster
films
Iron Man two and three the Avengers age
of Ultron Batman vs Superman star trek
into darkness mission impossible 5 films
a narrative have been inspiring people
since the 19th century to go out and do
great things and build great things
we're not trying to be the accuracy
police we're not fact checkers per se
what our goal is is to inspire more
scientists characters and better science
in mainstream media projects and that's
the story about the hotline for
scientists in Hollywood